there was an amazing press briefing
yesterday with kaylee mcenany who makes
our national hardcore pitter-patter
kayleigh mcinerney is there answering
reporters questions
and some of the questions don't really
see my question some of the questions
seem like activism like they were trying
to push her to do something and what
were the reporters trying to push her to
do
trying to push the president to do they
were trying to get them
to shut down not just some areas or a
hot spot with the virus
trying to get them to shut down the
entire country
this president is hard at work and he'll
continue to work you're doing everything
that you can possibly do when there are
still
waits for getting test results back when
you have declined to pose it
to impose a national mass mandate when
you're saying you won't shut down
the entire country again the president
of the minneapolis federal reserve he
said two days ago that he believed that
the only way to have a real
strong robust economic recovery
would be to shut the country down again
for a month to six weeks i know that
this idea of
short-term pain for long-term gain has
been
shot down before by president trump but
has has it been given
any more consideration given the recent
flare-ups across the country
these parasites are unbelievable these
left-wing journalists
hey so could you plea when i mean we
should
i look i'm not advocating one point or
another but we're going to shut down the
country right
look there's short-term pain for
long-term gain
do we have any reason to believe a
complete shutdown of our country
would give us any long-term gain
some establishment liberals told us that
that's the case
to shut down until the election but do
we have any evidence that that's true
remember they told us 15 days to slow
the spread i think they told us that
about 15 years ago
they did they did tell us but i think it
was about 140 days ago
i don't think that led to long-term gain
in fact i think the lockdown has caused
much much much more damage to people's
lives to the country as a whole
than the coronavirus has so far
so do we have any evidence of what
they're saying no of course not
they just want to shut down the country
so there's not even a glimmer of an
economic recovery so people are kept
out of work so people kept frustrated
and angry so that trump gets blamed for
it
you know the whole premise has been from
the left
just shut down for 15 days it'll be
it'll be painful but then it'll all be
so much better
and conservatives get fooled by it but
what happens you shut down for 15 days
and it doesn't make it easier to reopen
it makes it easier to remain shut down
for months which is what happened
same thing with the masks just wear the
masks and that'll make it easier to
reopen society
let me ask you something as the masks
have become more common has that led us
to progressively
reopen society no it's led us
progressively to shut it down even more
and now they say let's just shut down
the country for it'll be really quick
it'll be like four weeks
and then we'll reopen it'll be we'll go
like gangbusters for me once shame on
you
fool me twice shame on me fool me three
times what are we even doing
i hope you enjoyed that short segment
from the michael knowles show be sure to
check out the full episode linked in the
description
or download the podcast wherever you
listen to podcasts
[Music]
[Music]